[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored tonight the legendary dame
joan collins
is vladimir putin dying britain's former
spy chief thinks so and martin have
rattle over on the grand slam russia ban
the first disgrace prince andrew will
reportedly appear next to the queen at
one of the most important ceremonies in
the royal calendar gar today at windsor
castle royal editor at vanity fair katie
nichol and british socialite lady colin
campbell debated if he should be allowed
to weasel his way back into the royal
spotlight katie
this does great with me i have to say i
think if you're going to pay
a woman
a rumored 11 million dollars to make a
sex abuse case go away having said
you're going to fight it all the way to
clear your name and then he just caved
yeah i don't think you're entitled to
just slither back into public life in a
few months i agree with you i think it's
time for him to go away actually um in
the same way that that settlement just
sort of struck it all out the the
dignified and actually the respectful
thing to do for the queen and for the
royal family is to bow out gracefully as
gracefully as he possibly can this has
been a spectacular fall from angie he
doesn't have his title doesn't have his
honorary titles doesn't represent the
queen doesn't carry out official duties
um
i think it's very difficult then to
reconcile seeing him on a public stage i
know these events essentially can be
seen as private events the garter is
privately bestowed it's the highest
level the queen can give okay and this
is an important one because let's not
forget she's investing camilla and tony
blair i think so yeah okay less on that
but more importantly on camilla um this
is once again going to detract from all
of this and i think that just a lot of
people will be sitting and watching and
thinking why and i know from the
american audience that i write for every
time the queen has seen with andrew
it it it troubles them it does well also
they also think quite rightly um that
i've come to lady colin campbell now uh
first of all uh good evening to you
thank you for joining the show i i you
know i do think that for example
we give you know megan and harry a hard
time i think justifiably in most cases
um but this what they've done to be
honest pales into insignificance in my
opinion to a senior member of the royal
family paying millions of dollars to
make a sex abuse case go away
but you don't share this do you think
you should be able to come back
i certainly don't share this view first
of all my information was that its five
figures was the settlement and also each
party had to pay its own costs and
expenses i know the press keeps on going
on and on banging the drum about several
million pounds and million dollars i
don't know where they got it from
because this it's the settlement was
supposed to be confidential
so
how do you know it's not it's not
believable as your 10 or 20 figures well
how do you know how do you know it's not
it's confidential
well
how do my point is how do you know that
it's 11 million dollars no it's been
reported it's been reported from very
it's been reported from very good
sources it was 11 million dollars if
you're saying it was a a a much smaller
sum i'm just curious how you reported
from very good sources i was i was told
from from very good sources that it was
a five-figure sum that's not true i can
tell you i know categorically that's not
true
well you you mean you know categorically
i know 100 percent of what you've just
said is not true it's not a five-figure
settlement i know that for a fact
well i know categorically that's what i
was told and i believe my source is
rather more than yours okay well you
don't know who my source is but if you
did you wouldn't say that but look let's
move on to the wider point
whether it's
resources
to be honest
look whether it's five figures or
millions or whatever it finally was he
settled the case having said he was
going to fight it to clear his name and
i think if you do that as a senior
member of the royal family you should
not be allowed to continue in public
life
otto rubbish pairs with due respect i
mean since when
was this a country where you are guilty
until proven innocent this may play very
well in the court of popular uh
condemnation but the reality is in this
country as in all civilized countries
you are innocent until you are proven
guilty why didn't he clear his name he
kept saying he kept saying i'm going to
clear my name
why didn't he clear his name
why didn't he get a call why didn't she
she kept on she kept on saying she kept
on saying that she would never settle
uh that she wanted her day in court she
is an admitted procureus prostitute now
you're making allegations now which are
unsubstantiated
and i have to make that on the record
i'm sorry they are they are
unsubstantiated allegations i need
nothing that you're saying to she has
admitted nothing you're saying to attack
nothing
nothing you're saying to attack the
accuser lady colin will change the fact
that prince andrew who's nearly 30 years
her senior that he publicly declared
just a few months before the settlement
i will not settle this case i will have
my day in court i will clear my name and
then he settled with him she did the
same thing and she settled he's a senior
member of the royal family and she said
he was the one accused of sexual assault
of a of in america a minor and he
settled that case without clearing
excuses
for sexual purposes in either england or
the united states of america the states
that were concerned she was over the age
of consent you know pairs rarely you i
mean that's not true
i'm sorry that's not that's actually not
true she was under the age of one
she was considered a legal minor in at
least one of the american locations
where the sex was alleged to have
happened but my point is you say andrew
was getting that's not so
well that is so actually the state that
that's not so because the state of of
new york is is 16 years old or 17 and in
england it is over
she was 17 years old so i'm sorry that's
absolute rubbish no it's not
relationship over the age okay
i don't think
age of consent in american states it's
fine let's come back to you
on this i mean look emotions run high
about this kind of thing
and the bottom line for me is andrew
decided to settle it okay so when
someone settles it and doesn't have
their day in court having promised to to
me it's like well you're not even
proving you're innocent no you've just
paid off the case absolutely but i think
also you know if i can just move the
conversation on a little bit from this
the there is an underlying issue here
and and i think what this exposes is
that difficult situation that the queen
is in as monarch
and as a mother i agree
i was told by very close sort of the
queen that she had challenged
andrew asked him if he was innocent and
he told her repeatedly that he was now
she clearly believes him yeah and she's
done and as lady c says in fairness
innocent tour provenance we don't know
he's guilty we just know he didn't go
and have his day in court absolutely but
putting that aside the problem is i go
back to this is is the optics and for
someone who has settled out of court and
all the sort of murky image of that
really a time when we're wanting to see
the royal family united and at its best
behind the queen do we need andrew
tagging along as i say the graceful
thing would have been to exited quietly
he's not serving any purpose other than
to detract and make headlines in my
opinion for all the wrongs also on the
guard today being seen as a royal knight
in all the regalia really
that day honors chivalry yeah i mean are
we really going to be having andrew and
this is parading around in his gown
honoring chivalry we're in this kind of
club this is the problem
a sex abuse case anyway look go leave it
there katie thank you lady colin thank
you feisty as always appreciate you
joining me
uncensored next after a deadly shooting
at the u.s elementary school left 19
children and two teachers dead speak to
scarlet lewis who tragically lost her
six-year-old son jesse in the sandy hook
massacre of 2012. that's after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
19 children were shot dead at school in
ivaldi texas yesterday
they were all under the age of 12
slaughtered in their classroom by an 18
year old maniac who just bought the guns
he used for his 18th birthday present
these children's parents took them to
school yesterday morning their young
hearts joyful with excitement for
another day of education and fun with
their friends
but they never went home and they're
never going home
and those parents will never recover now
from the loss of their children
they were slaughtered by this 18 year
old lunatic who was then shot dead by
police
in the deadliest school massacre since
sandy hook for survivors and victims
families of a 2012 sandy hook massacre
in connecticut the attack at the rob
elementary school in texas brings up
chilling reminders of a very dark day in
american history scarlett lewis's son
jesse was just six years old when he was
killed along with 19 other students and
six adults and scarlett joins me now
scholar thank you so much
for joining me i i thought of all of you
because i was on air at the time in
america at cnm when this happened uh it
was an absolutely harrowing story to
report on as indeed had been the similar
massacre at dunblane in scotland in the
mid 90s and in fact this morning i had
an email exchange with one of the
mothers of one of the children who died
at dunblane because
i recognized that for all of you
trapped in this appalling club of
mothers and fathers who've lost kids to
these school massacres
when another one happens it must take
you all right back
to the day that you lost your own
children is that what it was like for
you when you heard about this
absolutely pierce i i i was living the
experience right alongside all of those
parents
when they were waiting to get word
whether their child was going to be
found dead or alive those hours those
torturous hours and then you know
my first thought this morning was
how they would wake up and and for one
split second forget
and then this crushing blow would come
down over them that
their child was dead that yesterday they
were planning
uh the summer fun and and today they're
going to have to start thinking about
writing an obituary they're going to
have to start planning for funerals and
it is
it was a gut punch to me and and so
incredibly painful and and honestly i
can't believe that i'm
standing here talking to you 10 years
after the murder of my own son jesse at
sandy hook alongside 19 of his first
grade classmates and six educators and
now here we have another one after
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
school shootings later and of course
columbine 20 years before and we are
still hearing the same tired narrative
it is so frustrating
you know there's the saying that the the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing again and again and expecting a
different result you could switch this
round and say that with these massacres
in america and the school shootings the
definition of insanity is doing nothing
again again and again and expecting a
different result you know i knew after
sandy hook that if there was no change
at all in the way that america was going
to respond to these massacres then
inevitably there would be more of them
i i felt the same way piers i i saw some
movement but
we're always a step behind and the
frustrating thing is
these are preventable every single one
and we're reactive and as you said we do
the same thing over and over expecting a
different result it's the definition of
crazy that's why
after jesse's murder
obama flew in he was talking about gun
control and i realized that that had
failed uh obviously for sandy hook and
so i took a different approach i decided
to focus on the root cause of the pain
and suffering that leads to these events
and so in other words offering
schools homes and communities skills and
tools that they can use that help kids
face their hurt and pain be able to
manage it
live with it grow through it be
strengthened by it and flourish i think
that this is absolutely a hundred
percent
necessary it should be in every single
school
uh and and and i'm actually on my choose
love bus tour right now you caught me in
new hampshire
working for governor sununu traveling
around the state
bringing love hope and healing to
communities here that we've been doing
through uh through the uh pandemic and
we will continue to do you do remarkable
work and it's very inspiring that out of
such an appalling tragedy you're able to
find the strength to do this and i
commend you for that i want to take you
back to what happened to your boy he was
six years old and he was an absolute
little hero because he was in the
classroom when the
the shooter adam lanza came in and his
gun jammed and your little lad jesse
shouted at his friends to get out of the
classroom which a large number of them
did i think eight or nine of the kids
got out and then he was shot dead uh a
absolute hero was that in keeping with
his character
absolutely absolutely that was jesse uh
and i i if he wasn't coming back as we
waited for those hours i knew that he
would have done something brave and when
the the shooter had shot his way through
the glass doors of sandy hook elementary
school he made a left
down the first grade hallway of course
he knew where that was because he had
attended that school
the principal and guidance counselor
were meeting with a parent they were
startled they opened the door to see
what
what the the the noise was all about
they were gunned down and then the
shooter turned into jesse's first grade
classroom everyone was scattered his gun
actually ran out of bullets at that time
and during the short delay that it took
him to change his clip
jesse called for his classmates to run
and he is credited with saving nine of
his classmates lives before losing his
own
no child should ever be asked to do that
in his in school i mean it is our
responsibility to keep our kids safe and
to address their mental health and
well-being and we have to start taking
that responsibility a lot more seriously
in fact we need to start making our kids
a priority scholar i could not agree
with you more i think it's i think the
desensitization of this generation of
kids is a massive problem i think it's
driven by endless exposure to shocking
imagery and videos and so on from social
media shared around you know they're
seeing stuff in real time happening
minutes after it happens whereas 40
years ago you would never have seen it
and i think it's a it's a massive
problem i'm awestruck by your courage
and your inspiration to be perfectly
honest you know i remember sandy hook so
vividly you know maybe upset just
remembering it as i thought about your
boy and all the others um so thank you
for what you're doing because we've got
to try and work our way through this and
there's not a simple solution and i just
want to end by saying again how heroic
your lad jesse was that day he saved the
lives of
so many of his little classmates and it
cost him his life but what an amazing
little hero he was and i wish you all
the very best with your campaigning keep
it up
thank you thanks pierce
frenchman lucas puert is the first
player to declare he won't play
wimbledon this year because there'll be
no ranking points it follows the
decision to penalize all england club
for banning russian and belarusian
players 18 times grand slam tennis
champion rattle over gave me her
thoughts martina thank you for joining
me we did discuss this a few weeks ago
didn't we and and things have really
escalated now where it's becoming this
massive furore uh i gotta say since we
last spoke i think i shared your view
then that punishing individuals uh
seemed the wrong way to punish putin um
but i then interviewed vladimir
klitschko the the ukrainian boxer last
week and he said this to me
the war is going on
they cannot participate in the next
olympic games they cannot participate at
any
athletic events
because
this war
is represented by russia
so atlas representing russia and there
is definitely connection
i'm going to say that when i listen to
him speaking so powerfully he did
slightly sway me i've got to be honest
because i i can just imagine a situation
where a russian tennis star
ends up winning a wimbledon trophy and
you know has it presented to him or her
by the duchess of cambridge for example
what a pr bonanza that would be for
vladimir putin right now and something
that we i just don't think as a country
could tolerate that kind of scenario
unfurling so i'm not sure that wimbledon
have had a lot of choice given the
pressure from the uk government to do
this
sure i i understand so much where uh the
players uh and people in the ukraine are
coming from a hundred percent i can
still relate to this
um i am thinking there's a big
difference between team events and
individual events
and also you have russian and belarusian
players on team sports for example
alexey ovichkin playing for the
washington capitals in the nhl not a
peep out of anybody that he should not
be playing
for for for that team plus he's a
massive supporter of vladimir putin on
top of that so you have a player like
rublev who has uh disowned the war he
had written on the camera no to war yet
he can't play
um so it's just you look there's no
winning situation here and now you have
a controversial decision if it was the
right thing i think we would not be so
ambivalent about it um both ways um
so it's
there's just no good way out of it bad
situation of course horrible situation
with the war bad situation with the with
with one button making this rule and now
another kind of iffy decision and not
not giving the points but
you just try to make the best out of a
horrible situation you were still
playing
if you were still playing martina at the
top of your game and may even be in the
running as you were of course many times
to win a wimbledon title uh what would
you have done if the points weren't
there to be won
would you have taken a view like naomi
osaka and said well actually in that
case i'm not going to play would you
taken a principled stand in support of
russian and belarusian tennis players
what would your view of being do you
think
no i would well first of all i would i
could care less that there were no
points uh given because i always play
for the trophies not the points and not
the money
so uh for me it was wimbledon and
nothing else and everything else came in
second so the points were
this is not an exhibition uh i i don't
understand that view that players
wouldn't play because there are no
points so you're playing for computer
ranking
uh i just wanted to hold that uh hold
the trophy uh that wonderful
venus roast dish so um
it's you know there's no good way out of
this but i don't understand the players
that say they don't want to play because
of points this is why you're playing
tennis right to get points onto the
computer and see your ranking going up
or down or whatever i could have cared
less when i won one but on i didn't know
that i became number one that i don't
like that in the press conference when
they told me by the way you're number
one i'm like oh great that's just carry
on the cake is i mean maybe osaka i've
got to say
barely a week goes by without naomi
osaka whining about something is she
just got all her priorities wrong should
she go back to just wanting to win big
trophies and keep quiet i
well it's kind of nice if you can walk
away from a potential what two million
pound uh uh you know payday
uh most people don't have that luxury uh
but uh i i just don't understand a
mentality and and uh i would like to sit
down with her and just tell her about
the history of wonder
uh and you know the russian players
volusion players if this was never would
never wouldn't occur to her that she
would not play right if they were
playing points weren't taken away so
uh i i don't understand that mentality
but i you know there's a lot of things
that i don't understand these days
well i think if they all had your
winning mentality trust me they win a
lot more tournaments because you were
one of the all-time greats martina
brilliant to talk to you thank you very
much
uncensored next former mi6 chief sir
richard dearlove tells me why he
believes putin will be out of power by
next year that's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
this propaganda machine portray him as a
strong fearless leader a recent images
of vladimir putin looking bloated
suggest otherwise former head of the
british secret intelligence so richard
dearlove tells me why he thinks putin
will be out of power by next year
richard great to see you
you are the real life m aren't you well
you were i was once
c
c not m see you a c i'm so sorry of
course you were you were higher up the
up in the chain a perfect person then to
talk about what is going on with ukraine
because a lot of people thinking
the way to stop this is to get to putin
in your previous life
would you have been contemplating using
a james bond like assassin to go in and
take him up i don't think that would
have been a practical approach to the
problem so no we did not it's a serious
question well it's a serious question i
have mooted the idea of assassinating
him as being the way to stop what is
going on do you think it would even if
not we're not in the state of war with
russia at the moment so that would not
in my view be an option which the
government could even consider but your
your belief is that putin is
sick and may not have long to live
uh
yeah my belief well take one look at him
if it was your father what would you
think yeah he was seriously ill i mean
i mean the fact that he shook hands at
that uh victory prayed with the with the
hand he doesn't use i think is a clear
indication that there's something
fundamentally wrong i mean let alone the
other symptoms that he's showing is it
more dangerous for the world
if he is say terminally ill with a
cancer or something and only he knows
this and his medical team
is that more dangerous because it may
encourage him to do something reckless
well i think if he's seriously ill his
judgment may be impaired
so you have a collision as it were
between the geopolitics of russia
and its loss of ukraine and putin's
health i think that's a pretty uh
unsavory combination of factors it's a
very unsettling time at the moment for
geopolitics you've got president biden
being quite forceful about taiwan and
what he may do taking the american
position to a slightly stronger place
and it's been before saying he would
engage militarily we've obviously got
ukraine you've got all the issues with
wheat and other produce now potentially
causing starvation especially in africa
middle east these are worrying times you
know massive inflation
what do you make of it all you've been
around the block if you don't mind me
saying for a few decades have you seen
anything quite like this
no probably not we're living in a period
of you know geopolitical well maybe we
could we should call it crisis
the pandemic's been probably the most
disruptive event socially and to an
extent politically since world war ii
and on top of that now we have a major
war on the european continent so
and let alone the other problems with
you know the price of energy the
situation with china
we have a concatenation
of crises some larger than others but
yes it's highly problematic
does social media amplify all this in
the sense that when you were running mi6
you you deal dealt with all sorts of
massive issues
are things actually worse now are they
are they just amplified by the fact that
social media definitely exaggerates and
amplifies the problem and let's say
increases the level of social anxiety
because the messages of broadcast say
widely into so many people but i mean i
think the situation is genuinely
worrying and difficult and you know we
have a variety of apparently insoluble
and difficult problems facing the
government facing any government facing
any nation state
what's the thing you meet miss
most about being
c in mi6 running our spies and what's
the thing you you miss least
well i think
being in a position where you know a lot
about what's going on
i i guess i could say
i never really had a boring day at work
in my life
not many people could say that
uh it's a privilege to be
at the center yeah and to know what's
going on also slightly terrifying though
i mean well
the job is not for somebody who's of a
nervous disposition let's put it like
that i think you need to be relatively
calm
in the way that you view crises which at
any moment can sort of escalate in front
of you
what am i pleased about well i think in
a way i'm pleased i'm not head of the
service any longer i mean i was in it
for a very long time
and i think i did my bit
and served my country
i'm very proud of that
but what was the moment if i could let
you relive it again what was the single
most memorable moment for whatever
reason of your tenure
oh i guess you it has to be 9 11 yeah
and the events of 9 11. and when that
happened i mean when you're in that job
you must know this is now your world has
completely changed so many did but were
you able to stay calm even in a moment
like that i think so
ask my colleagues and friends
i think i had a reputation for remaining
calm you a reputation for integrity
if you had been caught as the boss of
mi6 during a pandemic with severe
lockdowns
hosting leaving parties
having a large number of your staff 86
of them getting fines from the police
for having illegal lockdown breaking
parties would you have fallen on your
sword and done the honorable thing i
wouldn't have been
in that position right so what do you
make of the fact that the prime minister
was in that position uh i think i'm
gonna avoid comment on the practice you
don't have to sit on the fence anymore
so richard well i on that particular
issue i i'm going to sit on the fence
but i mean what what i would say is that
you know if if if you're in an
organization particularly if you're
leading an organization like the secret
intelligence service the issue of
integrity is absolutely crucial
and so you wouldn't have put yourself in
that position i mean there's a picture
coming out tonight from pippa carrera
from the daily mirror and it's a picture
of what is quite clearly a lavish amount
of alcohol for a party i mean there's
just no denying it do you think when we
get told as a public that's not a party
we're being taken from mugs a rich
all i would say is if you're a lawyer
it's quite difficult yeah describe what
thank you what a party is
so i think that that's my reply to that
difficult question final question for
you who should be the next james bond
after daniel craig
and should it ever ever be a woman
um i'm a traditionalist
and i think
it should be a man because that's the
way ian fleming conceived of the role
correct and uh so uh who would you like
to see do it nick well i've i've looked
at the list of the candidates and my
pick
would be and i'm i'm not an expert i
don't know but if i was you are you
actually you are well i mean
i'm an expert for the role yes um i
think the one who suits it best of the
list but i don't know all of them is
probably tom hiddleston really yeah
really yeah i think he ruined it with
the taylor swift ocean t-shirt and you
know more about that than i do i'm an
idris elba fan myself i think he'd be a
cracking well he would be good i agree
yeah but he's got that sort of steely
charm whether you need steely charm i
did actually pitch myself to barbara
broccoli only three months ago it would
have been rather i saw a big
a real c as m yes why not a great idea
seriously why don't you suggest a
fantastic director so richard what a
pleasure nice to meet you very nice
thank you very much for joining me
zachary daranovsky created the tick tock
account during the pandemic in the hope
of finding new friends he now has more
than eight million of them he surprises
strangers with random acts of kindness
and he's now raised thousands for good
causes in the process
it all really stemmed from when i was
depressed and borderline suicidal in
medical school i was studying medicine
at the university of sydney
and it was almost a cry for help at the
time i made a video about depression and
what i was going through um and then it
just took a life of its own over the
last 10 months so it started with
raising mental health awareness to then
unconditional love and kindness and then
i've been able to grow this thing to
almost 12 million followers in 10 months
and someone a few months ago said it'd
be nice if you could monetarily help
these people in which most situations
i've come across it's the people who
have the least want to give the most
um so it's all been community funded
this video right here where i'm
blindfolded hugging a stranger is i'm
blindfolded because i
didn't know how to connect with my
family and friends back home when i was
depressed and suicidal and i found it
much easier to connect with the stranger
i hug people because i haven't hugged
someone in two years and i tell
strangers every time i meet them that i
love them because no one told me they
loved me in two years right i mean
you've had you've got 8.5 million
followers on tick tock you've had 273
million likes on take time millions more
on other platforms
could you even imagine in your wildest
dreams when you started this that you'd
end up as this kind of tick-tock
samaritan sensation
absolutely not i made the first video to
find a friend and then continue medical
school so
this was never never my wildest dreams
what i thought i'd be doing right now
and how do you actually raise the money
i know you crowdfunded but how does that
work
so there's a donation link on all my
platforms that runs 24 7 so however much
i'm able to raise within that span
before i make the next video i then
directly have to give 500 away or a
thousand and then even more powerful i
find is when i find a stranger where
that money isn't enough i link gofundme
so we've raised nearly 250 000 in the
past couple months for strangers on top
of the fact of the videos
absolutely incredible look i found it
very moving your story
i love what you do we'd like to just do
a little tiny contribution towards it
because you've been kind enough to come
on the show so we'd love to just give
you a thousand dollars from piers morgan
uncensored the next time you're out
there uh just give it to whoever you
think would deserve that and that's just
our little way of saying thank you for
the interview and thank you for what
you're doing it's an amazing thing
pierce morgan thank you so much for that
that
you have no idea how much that means to
me thank you thank you thank you and for
this opportunity to connect and yeah
thank you so much well thank you exactly
we need more people like you in the
world good luck to you
uncensored next it's the glamorous the
glittering the fantastically
irrepressible dame joan collins we think
it was only fitting that we roll out the
first ever red carpet on piers morgan
unsensing for the great lady the
hollywood legend will be here with me
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
well my next guest is true hollywood
royalty with a glittering career
spanning seven decades awarded the dame
hood by prince charles with services to
her services charity in 2015. and next
week will be part of the dames in jags
procession at the queen's jubilee
pageant i'm thrilled to say dame joan
collins hello how are you i'm great but
i want to congratulate you on having
your own show thank you i think it's
great
it doesn't really feel like my
instruction you're here i feel like
you're anointing me like it's almost
after the queen is the next best thing
to a royal business oh please come on
now you're part of the dames in jags
what is this the hags in jags
[Laughter]
well after they i mean this thing is
going to be so enormous i mean so
fantastic it's going have you ever been
to the um thanksgiving macy's
thanksgiving parade it's going to be
like that they're going to have all
these floats they're going to have um
people dancing and singing and all kinds
of people on it and then we are coming
down in these amazing vintage jaguars
open
i've got a white one and twiggy's there
and dame darcy bustle and um i can't
remember who the others are you must
have it written down for a great load of
great dates well i think so and then we
are going to go around waving gracefully
i hope
to um the populace who are going to line
up and then we're going to go and
hopefully um go into one of the boxes
and watch the rest of it but it's very
exciting because i'm such a monarchist
and i'm such a royalist and i love the
queen so much that to have been asked is
a great is really you've been in you've
been in movies 70 years the queen has
been on the throne 17. i know it's quite
amazing and there you are together but
she's a remarkable woman isn't she she
is the most inspirational woman i think
that ever has lived in my lifetime i
don't know i never knew my mother teresa
or joan of arc but i mean they were
probably pretty good but no she is
because she's so
down to earth and gentle and humorous
and
she's got through all of these dreadful
things that have happened to her i mean
there really have been some awful things
that she's had to deal with and she does
it with such grace and the fact that she
has never ever commented on anything
that's going on no interviews nothing
but even an aside because you know there
are people there liberating
and they could say that she said oh i
think this this play is ghastly as we
all do when we go to see something but
the last time i saw her we had it was at
buckingham palace
and we were talking about pygmalion my
fair lady because some students
gave um a performance and she's so
knowledgeable about the theater
and we had really very nice chat no i
just love her she's been a part of my
life i kept a scrapbook of her wedding
to
prince philip when i was a school girl
we were all madly in love with prince
philip as well you
being married yes but look at that man
who just died yeah with a broken heart i
know more than the story from texas
i mean imagine they've got four children
oh no the teacher had been teaching
there for many years she gets shot dead
by this lunatic and then within 24 hours
her husband literally dies of a broken
heart this was his childhood sweetheart
those four kids now have no parents oh
my god it's heartbreaking it's beyond
terrible what goes on with these things
i don't understand why if somebody posts
pictures of themselves on social media
buying guns talking about guns saying i
want to kill people why they can't be
by the fbi or the cia or whoever goes
literally put on instagram pictures of
the two ar-15 rifles but here's the
point he was 18 and when he turned 18 a
couple of weeks ago he was legally
allowed to buy these guns he went and
bought his guns he couldn't have bought
a beer that would have been illegal he
couldn't buy a kinder surprise chocolate
egg they're illegal in the whole of
america because the toys may choke you
an 18 year old boy could buy two ar-15
semi-automatic rifles and then go and do
what he did can you imagine being a
mother and hearing that or even being a
mother now and sending your kids to
school and thinking are they going to be
safe
i mean you always thought your children
were going to be safe i actually emailed
a friend of mine who's one of the
dunblane mothers because every time one
of these things happens i just can't
imagine what they go through and i sent
her a note and she replied a very nice
heartfelt email but it always takes them
straight back when they have this well
of course it does and their kids never
grow up and and just what they have to
go through is so unthinkable i think
it's i think the whole thing is
unthinkable and i think the whole thing
of somebody mentally wanting to kill
children babies
which is what is going on in ukraine as
well but we don't seem to talk about
that anymore well that's another thing
you know ukraine's disappearing from the
news agenda i know which is what
vladimir putin wants he's carrying
of course he wants us to stop talking
about it let him just carry on seizing
the country it's just appalling which is
what he's doing you know but is it true
that she's very ill i keep on hearing
these rumors people say that i mean who
the hell knows all i do know is he is
raising cities to the ground literally
destroying them
he's up there with him yeah and i think
his aspiration is to seize ukraine and
then to try and seize other countries of
course
finland yeah norway what do you make of
party gate boris johnson you know boris
johnson you've been at parties with
borrowers yeah he was my boss once when
he was at the state station and he was a
spectator yeah um what do i think of it
i have to say i haven't really
gotten involved in it totally but i
haven't exactly seen you know fizzing
bottles of champagne and lots of and
people sitting down to me a party is
people sitting well they had a few big
ones i mean
there have been some big ones and they
were vomiting and fighting and breaking
stuff yeah but
ultimately it's not about partying what
it's about it's about the fact that they
were doing all this breaking the laws
they had made
and everybody else including the queen
who at phillips funeral had to sit on
her own that tragedy because she wanted
to obey the rules and the night before
they were partying in downing street
till 4 a.m which i think is unforgivable
well i do too i think it's terrible but
what are you going to do i mean you're
going to get rid of boris who are you
going to bring in actually yes
i do think when a prime minister breaks
their own rules and gets fined by the
police for it during a pandemic that's a
resignation of this it used to be the
old days men would fall on their sword
as a matter of honor i don't think he
knows how to spell the word well who do
you suggest then is our next prime
minister somebody that can restore a bit
of integrity
somebody who's the somebody there's
always somebody there every time you
think i don't think there's anything
irreplaceable you i mean you are but
you're irreplaceable
and i don't know about that about
another thing wimbledon today has
announced that they're removing from the
honors board
ms and miss before the names of previous
winners they want to make it gender
neutral
what are your thoughts
i think that's just the way everything
is going isn't it what about the men
well the men they they just call them
you know en djokovic i
it's just something that's been going on
and it's um something to me that you
know since emily pankhurst women have
fought fought for for equal rights so i
suppose this is them saying well this is
equal rights you know the man what if
they say to you right you can't be
called a dame anymore because it's two
female titles well they haven't said
that to me but what if they did what if
they came for your dame hood i just
threw it to them
you wouldn't you love being a gamer
i love being a dame i mean
it's it's very flattering
in britain particularly because people
know what it is in the rest of the
country they don't know i mean in the
rest of the world
in america a dame the famous you know
something from damon runyan frank
sinatra to call his girlfriend
yeah and uh of course in in europe like
in france percy sometimes says to
somebody damn jungle oh dom dom don't
you know they think this is no i like i
like it of course but you know very
old-fashioned so when you see when you
see this debate where politicians can't
even say what a woman is
now you're now
now we're not going to get on that
subject i do not a proof of people
saying that of course not because it's
just not fair it's not right and um
thank you very much but what is a woman
what is a woman me
[Laughter]
senior without her over there
there's plenty of us
but are you worried that in this trans
debate because i support trans rights
defenders so do i of course i just don't
like the attack on women's rights that
some of the activists are driving where
you have in sport this apparent
unfairness now going on what do you
think when you see that
well i don't watch sport no but you know
what i'm talking about well i know what
you're talking about yes and i know what
you want me to say i don't need to say
anything
to agree with you no no this is
uncensored
well of course it's uncensored i think
that a person should be
who they feel that they are
and who they
but i do believe
i can't say this i can't you can't no i
can't why you feel like you've got did
you make it i can't because i don't want
to get hate though you see but you've
gone through your entire career saying
exactly what you always think no i
haven't yes you have no i'll break your
diaries
i've never i've never gotten into the uh
politics of biology okay no i haven't i
understand why people don't want to go
there yes i don't want to go there we're
talking about what about madonna who's
auditioning for a new boy toy
you're kidding she is no you've just
made that up no she's apparent she wants
him to be hard-bodied what do you mean
hard-bodied and young oh that's right we
were with her son rocco yeah
last summer and he said you know my
mother says that she will not sleep with
anybody over the age of 25.
i said no
you're kidding
that's never been your rule has it no i
don't have rules
rules i'm very happily married with 20
years you didn't come to our anniversary
party i wasn't here as you know i was in
australia i know i know it's a fantastic
part of the great person as he always is
he's lurking in the wings like a
protective knife don't say that we're
lurking he's like
look at him
standing he just got he saved me from
the most embarrassing wardrobe
malfunction party yes i was talking to
richard arnold your friend yeah and he
was terribly funny he made me laugh and
the whole zipper in the back of my dress
went
and i'm sitting there with a completely
gaping open and there's loads of
photographers was a big party
and i said to percy i don't know what to
do i know there was another dress i was
possibly going to wear because the theme
was red white or blue because it was a
jubilee party so i said you know the
white dress that i left in the wardrobe
do you think you could bring it
so he went luckily we don't live too far
away and i changed into another dress
and we were spared what would it be
perhaps a delightful incident i had to
say that for at least half an hour i had
a huge feather bow which i kept on
putting on christopher biggins
around his neck he really liked that
and uh but it was fantastic
i've got to leave it there
but it was a wonderful interview it's
great to see that and i cannot wait to
see you in your jack on sunday at the
fact he's going to be amazing yes i'm
going to see you there see you already
i'll see you there okay yeah and i
thought i'm staying for dinner tomorrow
night
i'm a lucky guy new restaurant and
dinner with joan collins let me tell you
is hilarious lovely to see you great to
see you that's it from me whatever
you're up to this weekend make sure it's
uncensored good night
[Music]
talk tv is going to be the kind of
channel that when you sat there as i do
in this industry as a journalist and you
think about what a channel should be
what is missing out there you know
people have given things a go they've
tried to say look this is where we're
gonna have common sense and real views
and represent what ordinary people think
and it's never really happened and
actually talk tv has come along it
absolutely is about to nail that very
thing
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora solomon texas
officials say it was the wrong decision
not to storm a classroom where a gunman
killed 19 children and two teachers
police have been criticized after it was
confirmed the gunman roamed outside for
12 minutes before entering
more tory mps have called on boris
johnson to go following the su-grey
report three mps have called on the
prime minister to quit including sir bob
neal alicia kearns and earlier paul
holmes quit as a home office aide talk
tv has learned up to three people a day
are now dying whilst waiting for an
ambulance in the uk one nhs
whistleblower told the news desk extreme
staff shortages have left chelmsford in
essex with just one ambulance on call
throughout an entire night that's all
for now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign